[Music]
uh but anyway look look here's the thing
you want to give a final i think we have
a little time so before we leave how
about you want to give a little final
thought for the ladies you know and
we'll spell the t-h-o-t do you have a
final thought for the ladies
uh
you know
there's a lot going on in our country
now there is
there is here i put some music for you
go ahead
you know our nation is um
more divided than ever
between the uh gun violence
roe versus wave the inflation and
everything else so true um so true
preach and i think that uh
some words that might comfort you in
these dark times
is stop being a bunch of baby killing
[ __ ] [ __ ]
wow so deep
so deep so [ __ ] deep
and uh you know uh what did jerry
springer used to say be good to each
other be good to each other be good to
yourself and be good to you
be good to yourself and be good to each
other there you go and uh stop killing
babies you [ __ ] [ __ ]
hi emmanuel rodriguez here the guy who
plays royce lopez on the show look we
had a lot of fun here today
but i just want to remind you
that the the moment women were allowed
to vote you were not allowed to drink
yeah you know folks we have a lot of fun
here on this show i'll tell you what's
no joke
merch is putting his leg up on a desk
right now
you know we like to have a lot of fun on
this show but uh i'll tell you what is
no laughing matter
you murdering millions of black babies
fun's over fun's over [ __ ]
be good to yourselves and each other
now you have to go pay for a prostitute
with a check like jerry springer did
have fun getting a coat hanger shoved up
your [ __ ] you forgot speed